when Groucho at the end of his life
would go on dick cavett or Merv Griffin
or any of these shows yes got very old
and very feeble and he was no longer
Groucho I'm thinking that's why you
walked away from Seinfeld even though
you could have done another season I'm
guessing this is your last stand-up
special for Netflix because you do not
want to end up like Groucho where you
appear less than perfect than one of
these specials am i right thank you I
think you got me there
yeah you got me there I you know I don't
like seeing old people on TV people in a
deteriorated state i I am I am a
perfectionist that way that's why I'm
obviously never did another TV series
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna try and beat
that I can't break that when I was
watching this much like oh this is gonna
be jerries lair especially got it right
he's not gonna want to [ __ ] up he's not
gonna want to do one more and then you
know stay two longer the party but I was
thinking I would like to know what you
were thinking during this Cove at 19 I
mean I think I wouldn't want to see a
special material to do another special
but I always like to give a little less
than you really want a little less don't
you think that's if you look back at all
the stuff I've done like this TV series
we could have done one two three more
years the reason people still love that
show is we didn't wear it out it's true
you know and I so I like that I like I
like minimalizing things but isn't it a
little sad that we're not gonna hear
maybe your observations on Kovan 19
because you're gonna go I can't do
another special blah blah blah blah blah
wish the world was a little less
judgmental and you weren't so hard on
yourself you didn't put the world it's
like this about it's what I like I'm
doing what I like
you do what you like Howard that is the
genius of Howard Stern I'm gonna do it
the way I want to do it and that's what
people respond to that's what they like
they don't want you catering to them
they want you catering to yourself
that's your art
you